Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist the king of our Olympic podcast trilogy. So Tolkien originally began The Lord of the Rings thinking it would be one short book, and it turned into three monsters. We decided to do a podcast on the ancient Olympicsics and then we decided to do the modern olympics and that's turned into two podcasts um just on the modern olympics it definitely won't be three because i don't think we have enough material but we have tons of good stuff don't we tom the modern olympics what a weird i'm hoping that you do i'm less knowledgeable about this that's right this
谢谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist
is very much your patch i can talk talk about Daley Thompson for hours. Yeah, Daley Thompson, but also the Cold War, I guess. Yeah, which is big. The great backdrop to this. It is, it is, absolutely. So, in the previous one, we got to the Second World War. Yeah. And London was due to host the 1944 Games.
这是你的专长。我可以讲 Daley Thompson 讲几个小时。是的，Daley Thompson，还有冷战，我想是的。是的，这很重要。这是一个伟大的背景。确实，绝对是。所以，在上一期节目中，我们讲到了第二次世界大战。是的。伦敦原本定于 1944 年举办奥运会。
Obvious reasons, couldn't, because London was busy with other things. But in the wake of that, london gets the games in 1948 yeah and it's blitzed it's bombed out it's austerity games is london is in a worse condition in 1948 than it probably would have been in 1944 because austerity is bitten so deep kicked in yeah um so that the um we talked in the in the first part about the problems that people had with the swimming people kind of contracting typhoid because it had been set in a lagoon or getting caught up on the currents of rivers there is a swimming pool in the the london games um but it has a massive crack due to bomb damage and so all the way through they have to
显而易见的原因，未能举办，因为伦敦当时正忙于其他事情。但在这之后，伦敦获得了 1948 年奥运会的主办权，当时它经历了狂轰滥炸，是一届紧缩的奥运会。1948 年的伦敦，其状况可能比 1944 年还要糟糕，因为紧缩政策影响深远，已经开始发挥作用。所以我们曾在第一部分中谈到人们在游泳方面遇到的问题，有人因为游泳池设在泻湖中而感染了伤寒，或者被河里的水流卷走。伦敦奥运会确实有一个游泳池，但由于炸弹袭击而产生了一条巨大的裂缝，因此在整个比赛过程中，他们必须
keep topping it up that's a good story that's so that basically conforms to i mean american athletes must have been utterly unsurprised by that that must have absolutely conformed to their image of 1940s london as this sort of gray shabby decay yes which it was kind of 1948 i mean 1984 it's um absolutely it's the city of and the athletes stay in RAF camps, don't they? So it's so kind of in the shadow of the war. They even... Because everybody's on rationing, they get given the special rations
不断地往里面加水。这真是个好故事，基本上符合——美国运动员对此一定完全不感到意外，这绝对符合他们对 20世纪 40 年代伦敦那种灰暗、破败、衰落的印象。是的，1948 年确实有点那种感觉——我是说，1984 年……绝对是一座……而且运动员们住在皇家空军（RAF）的营地里，对吧？所以它带有战争的阴影。他们甚至……因为每个人都在实行配给制，他们得到了发放给矿工、煤矿工人的那种特殊配给。是的。所以……
that are given to miners, to coal miners. Yes. So... Yeah, but also, Dominic, they get given soap, but they're asked to bring their own towels. Bring your own... That's's great that's like where don't people when they go on holiday in scandinavia they often take their own sheets when they book
是的，不过，多米尼克，他们还发了肥皂，但被要求自带毛巾。自带……太棒了，就像人们在斯堪的纳维亚度假时那样，他们经常在预定这类木屋和小木屋时带上自己的床单。这里有一种“你知道的，你自己带东西”的精神。也许奥运会也应该以这种原则来举办，这会消除一些狂妄自大，是的，打破一些……打破一些……是的。奥运村，你知道的，你们都应该自带毛巾。总之，这就是伦敦奥运会。他们当时已经有点脱节了，不是吗？我的意思是，出于完全可以理解且甚至可以说是令人钦佩的原因，伦敦奥运会打破了我们在上一集讨论过的 1936 年的模式。所以在上一集中，我们讨论了洛杉矶和柏林这两届奥运会，它们开创了现代奥运会：有火炬、有火炬接力、有领奖台、有奏国歌、有法西斯式的标志。但1948年的伦敦似乎并没有这些，对吧？一切都有点破破烂烂的，有点……但这种破旧恰恰成了重点，不是吗？是的，这就是重点。
these kind of cabins and chalets and stuff there's this sort of spirit of you know you bring your own stuff and whatnot maybe the olympics should be done on that principle it would sort of remove some of the hubris yes puncture some would. Puncture some of the... Yes. Yeah, the Olympic village, you know, you should all be bringing your own towel. So anyway, so that was the London Olympics. And they've sort of lost touch at that point, haven't they? I mean, for utterly understandable
我是说，这才是重点。甚至连宽松的裤子之类的东西也是。我想唯一建造的基础设施是半英里长的人行道，用来把行人从一个地方送到另一个地方。但显而易见的是，基本上就这些了。可以说，他们对奥运基础设施的态度比我们现在健康得多，因为他们有其他地方要把钱花在上面，而且也是因为他们对 36 年的过度行为产生了厌恶，因为我认为即使在那个时候，
and indeed perhaps admirable reasons, the London Olympics have broken with the 1936 pattern that we talked about in the last episode so in the last episode we talked about having two games los angeles and berlin created the modern olympics with the torch with the with the relay carrying the torch with the podiums with the playing of anthems with the sort of fascistic iconography but l But London in 1948 doesn't really seem to have that, does it? It's all a bit sort of shabby and a bit sort of... But shabbiness becomes the point, doesn't it? Yeah, it is the point.
柏林奥运会在希特勒及其崛起掌权、绥靖政策以及世界对其实质上的盲目包庇的故事中，开始扮演这种极其恶魔般的角色。不过，从 1948 年开始的故事却变得越来越奢侈，涉及基础设施、电视和冷战对抗，以至于战争中的胜利者、大国——苏联——没有来到伦敦，不是吗？它似乎在意识形态上消失了，据说它不赞同这种科林蒂安精神（体育精神）。这并不奇怪，但 1952 年在芬兰赫尔辛基举办的奥运会，当然处于一种阴影之下，在某种程度上可以说是受苏联庇护的。这就是最迷人的地方：它是西方阵营和苏联阵营之间维恩图的中心。在那里，苏联确实参加了比赛，而且有一个精彩的对比：
I mean, that's the whole point. Even baggy trousers and stuff. I think the only infrastructure that is built is half a mile of pavement to get pedestrians from somewhere to to somewhere else but i mean for obvious reasons that's basically it they had they had a much more arguably a much healthier attitude towards olympic infrastructure than we do now because they had other things to spend money on but also because there's a revulsion from the excesses of 36 because i think even at that point
美国的第一位女性金牌得主是玛格丽特·阿博特（Margaret Abbott），我们在前一期节目中聊过她，她基本上是“不小心”赢得了比赛——当时在学习艺术，这是一张她参赛的辉煌照片，她穿着长长的白裙子，戴着一顶帽子，（你知道的）带着一种辉煌的爱德华时代的外观。苏联的第一位女性奥运金牌得主是尼娜·罗马什科娃（Nina Romashkova），她赢得了女子铁饼冠军。她是斯塔夫罗波尔师范学院体育系的毕业生，而且她看起来确实非常符合这个身份。好吧，你根本无法想象她戴着某种帽子、象牙色帽子、看起来像海伦娜·伯翰·卡特（Helena Bonham Carter）的样子。她不会去撑船游河，她绝不会去撑船游河，我猜她会把船撑沉的。可以这么说，她浑身都是硬邦邦的肌肉。而且我猜，
the berlin games are beginning to assume this sort of incredibly diabolical role in the story of hitler and his rise to power and appeasement and the world's sort of blinding themselves but the realities of his regime the story from 1948 onwards though is increasingly extravagant yeah infrastructure tv and cold war rivalry so that the soviet union victor in the war great power yeah um does not come to london hasn't it it disappeared ideologically supposedly it disapproves of this you know the corinthian spirit i mean unsurprisingly but 1952 at helsinki and finland of course is in a shadowy way yeah kind of vaguely under the soviet aegis that's what's fascinating it's the venn diagram it's the center of the venn diagram between the western and and the the soviet bloc um there the soviets do compete and there's there's a kind of
这种模式为苏美对抗奠定了基础，这种对抗一直持续到——我想你知道的——80 年代遭到抵制的奥运会。是的，没错，莫斯科和洛杉矶。我认为苏联——所以苏联在此之前已经有好几年了——有着将体育视为宣传工具、将体育作为宣扬苏联体制现代性的工具的历史。因此，例如，他们曾派遣足球队到英国巡回比赛，并且踢出了一种被认为更具集体性、更先进、更进步的比赛。我认为这种——我的意思是人们谈论“苏联人”（Homo sovieticus），即所谓的苏联人，其理念是苏联人，尤其是苏联女性，随着时间的推移，特别是苏联女性——
wonderful contrast between the first female gold medal winner that america has who's margaret abbott we talked about in the previous one who wins by accident basically wins by accident was studying um art and this kind of glorious photo of her competing she's got long white skirts she's got a hat um you know kind of gloriously edwardian look um the first um woman to win a gold medal for the soviet union um is uh nina ramashkova who wins the women's discus and she is an alumna of the physical training faculty of the stravropol pedagogical institute and she very very much looks like it okay you you could not imagine her in a kind of hat you know ivory hat looking like helena bonhamham Carter she wouldn't go punting she would not go punting she'd sink the punt I think it's fair to say um she's solid muscle yeah um and I guess that that
几乎就像超人和女超人一样，多亏了苏联科学的应用，他们将超越所有西方竞争对手。正如我们所知，这成为了苏联以及后来的东德、捷克斯洛伐克、匈牙利等当局的一种狂热迷恋。所以这对奥委会来说是个问题，对吧？基本上，那种科林蒂安式的理想在共产主义社会里根本吃不开，而且苏联人对于为了让他们夺冠而对运动员进行长达四年的专项训练毫无心理负担。带有讽刺意味的是，他们有点类似于古代奥运会中那些非常贵族的形象。他们确实是，而且从技术上讲他们是业余选手，对吧？我的意思是，这些东欧和俄罗斯的选手总是
that kind of establishes a template for the Soviet American rivalry that will run right the way up till I guess you know the boycotted Olympicslympics of the 80s yeah that's right moscow and la and i think the soviet union so the soviet union already had for a few years i had a history of sport as propaganda sport as a um as a vehicle for proclaiming i think the key thing is proclaiming the modernity of the soviet system so they'd sent for example football teams to tour um england and they had played you know what was perceived to be a more collective more advanced more progressive game and i think this sort of i mean people talk about homo sovieticus the sort of soviet man and the idea was that soviet man indeed soviet woman particularly soviet woman as it became um
技术上的业余选手。他们可能在军队里，或者他们可能是——你知道的——这种对话中的老师、警察或类似的人。但当然，现实情况是他们把所有时间都用来训练，而且确实在像 70 年代那样被注入化学物质，以此来打破规则并获得优势。这种做法有多少？很多，是的，很多。这是一个极其庞大的计划。特别是——东德是最著名的例子。到了 70 年代和 80 年代，你知道，我认为他们有一个庞大的、由国家赞助的兴奋剂计划。当然，也有所有这些恐怖故事，特别是关于东德女性的，她们基本上被迫接受所有这些治疗，无论她们
were that they were almost kind of supermen and superwomen that thanks to the appliance of soviet science they would outstrip all their western competitors and this became an obsession as we know for the sort of soviet and then of course the east german czechoslovakian hungarian so on authorities so this is a problem for the olympic committee isn't it that basically that kind of corinthian ideal doesn't play in a communist society and the soviets have absolutely no compunction about training people for four years yeah solely with the aim of getting them i mean ironically they're they're kind of more like the very aristocratic figures in the ancient olympics they are and they're technically amateurs aren't they i mean they're always these
愿不愿意。如果你想成功的话。对于东德人来说，这是因为他们作为曾经的德国的一部分在竞争吗？所以他们的目标是……因此，当西德人获得慕尼黑奥运会的主办权时，我猜这一定给他们注入了强心剂。是的，绝对的。我认为绝对是这样。而且我认为到了 80 年代，它几乎成了自身的讽刺。我的意思是，我作为男孩还记得看东德运动员比赛时，BBC 评论员语调中的那种厌世情绪。
eastern european and and russian competitors are are technically amateurs they may they might be in the army or they might be you know this sort of conversation teachers yeah a policeman or something like this but of course the reality is they're spending all their time training and indeed being pumped with as as certainly by the 70s being pumped with chemicals um to sort of bend the rules and give them that give them the advantage so how much is that being done a lot yeah a lot that's a massive program that's a particularly i mean east germany is the most famous example east germany by the 70s and 80s you know i think they have this colossal state sponsored doping program and of course there are you know um all these horror stories about particularly east german women who are basically forced to take all these treatments whether they
“事实上，又有一个铁饼被扔出去了五英里。”是的，绝对的。被一个看起来像无敌浩克或类似的人扔的。我的意思是，嘲笑这个很容易，但背后其实有真正悲惨的故事。因为当然，他们真的别无选择，如果你选择退出，如果你被认为很有天赋却选择退出这个系统，
want to or not really if you want to succeed and for these germans is that because they are competing as you know one half of of course of what had been is that because they are competing as one half of what had been Germany? So they are targeting... And so when the West Germans get the games at Munich, I guess that must kind of turbocharge it. Yeah, absolutely. I think absolutely. And I think by the 80s, it had become almost a parody of itself. I mean, I can remember as a boy watching the East German athletes and the sort of world weariness in the BBC commentators' tones.
对你家庭的后果可能会非常严重。你知道的，你会失去机会，在住房名单上降级，失去各种各样的额外津贴，被标记为某种怀疑论者或国家敌人。因此，尤其是对这些女性来说，压力是极其巨大的。这不仅在东德。我的意思是，你读到关于罗马尼亚的纳迪亚·科马内奇（Nadia Comaneci）等人的故事。我的意思是，纳迪亚·科马内奇在 70 年代和 80 年代初承受了巨大的压力，因为她是齐奥塞斯库政权在全世界的绝对象征。所以她有非常——这简直是一种窒息。不过齐奥塞斯库是——我的意思是，
Actually, another hammer is chucked five miles. Yeah, exactly. By somebody who looks like the Incredible Hulk or something. I mean, it's easy to laugh about it, but there were real tragic stories kind of behind it because, of course, they didn't really have a choice because if you chose to opt out, if you were identified as talented and you chose to opt out of the system the consequences
他稍微有点——稍微有点游离于外，不是吗？所以美国人抵制莫斯科奥运会，因为苏联刚刚入侵了阿富汗；然后，当苏联人抵制洛杉矶奥运会时，齐奥塞斯库确实去了。嗯，因为罗马尼亚处在一个稍微半独立的状态……我的意思是，罗马尼亚在鱼与熊掌兼得。虽然不如南斯拉夫那样，但罗马尼亚确实在鱼与熊掌兼得。所以它试图从西方获得外汇，它在为自己定位。
for your family would could be very grave you know you would miss out you'd move down the housing list miss out on lots of perks of various kinds be identified as sort of skeptics or enemies of the state so the pressure on these women in particular was absolutely intense. And that's not just in East Germany. I mean, you read the stories about people like Nadia Comaneci, for example, in Romania. I mean, Nadia Comaneci was put under immense pressure in the 70s and early 80s because she was the absolute symbol of Ceausescu's regime around the world. And so she had very, it was just kind of stifling but chachescu is i mean
我的意思是，这也是齐奥塞斯库被英国女王授予勋章的原因之一。记住，他来到白金汉宫，我想，并被授予了某种勋章。他住在卧室里，不是吗？嗯，他是因为罗马尼亚正试图把自己定位为东欧共产主义温情脉脉的一面，而这显然具有讽刺意味，它完全、彻底不是这样。但是，是的，所以齐奥塞斯库——没错，他正试图掌控这一点。那么，你是否意识到这对美国和苏联来说有多重要？是的，非常重要。在奖牌榜上击败对方是绝对至关重要的。因此，苏联在 50 和 60 年代非常成功，并且——并且——从一开始就爆发了对抗。因此，经典的早期对抗发生在 1956 年的墨尔本。
he's slightly he's slightly kind of at a remove isn't he so the the americans boycott moscow because the soviets have just invaded afghanistan and then and then when the soviets boycott los angeles chusescu does go. Well, because Romania is in a slightly semi-detached... I mean, Romania is having its cake and eating it. Not as much as Yugoslavia, but Romania is having its cake and eating it. So it's trying to get currency from the West. It's sort of positioning itself.
所以那是 1956 年 12 月，那是苏伊士危机之后，但更关键的是，那是在红军镇压匈牙利起义之后。匈牙利和苏联之间举行了一场具有里程碑意义的水球比赛。所以匈牙利人非常擅长水球——我的意思是，谁会想到呢？我想他们在布达佩斯有泡温泉的传统，对吧？也许这就是他们这么厉害的原因。是的。所以匈牙利人，我想他们是卫冕冠军，他们已经训练了很久，他们有这场比赛——这是一场四分之一决赛或者
I mean, this is one of the reasons Ceausescu was decorated by the Queen. Remember, he comes to Buckingham Palace, I think, and is given some sort of order he stays in the bedroom doesn't he um he is because Romania is trying to position itself as the cuddly face of eastern European communism which obviously ironically it completely and utterly wasn't um but yeah so Ceausescu is exactly he's trying to steer this and so do you have a sense of how important it was to to both america and the soviet union yes massive each other in the medal tables it's absolutely massively important so the soviet union is very successful in the 50s and 60s um and and there are there are there are confrontations starting right away so the the classic early confrontation is in Melbourne in 1956.
别的什么，我记不太清了。所以那是 56 年 12 月，他们与俄罗斯人进行了这场比赛。这场比赛被称为“水中血战”，这就是它流传下来的原因。因为最后的打斗太激烈了，其中一个名叫埃尔文·扎多尔（Ervin Zador）的匈牙利人被拳击或肘击了。他有一秒钟把视线从俄罗斯对手身上移开，去问裁判一个问题。接下来的事情他知道了，他的鼻梁骨被打断了，鲜血正从脸上喷涌而出。
So December 1956, that's after the serious crisis, but it's also crucially after the Red Army's repression in Hungary of the Hungarian uprising. And there's this landmark water polo match between Hungary and the USSR. So the Hungarians are very good at water polo i mean who would i guess they've got their tradition of baths haven't they in budapest maybe that's why they're so good at each other yeah um so the hungarians i think are the reigning champions and they've been training for ages and they have this match um it's sort of a quarterfinal or
观众——主要是匈牙利的某种匈牙利裔澳大利亚人——开始大喊大叫，许多人开始向苏联球员吐口水，比赛在一场大规模的斗殴中结束。
something i can't remember exactly so it's de 56th, they have this match with the Russians. It's called the Blood in the Water match, that's how it's gone down. Because there was so much fighting at the end, one of the Hungarians, a guy called Ervin Zador, is punched or elbowed. He takes his eye off his Russian opponent for a second to ask the referee something. And the next thing he knows, his nose has been broken and there's blood pouring
匈牙利人以 4 比 0 获胜。谁赢了？匈牙利人赢了。而且我想他们赢得了金牌。但他们的许多球员叛逃了，包括那个被打出血的家伙——埃尔文·扎多尔。怪异的是，他最后竟然成了加利福尼亚的一名水球教练。哇。所以，是的，就在那里，你拥有了绝对的……我的意思是，这是一个故事。
from his face. The crowd, which was mainly Hungarian sort of Hungarian Australians they start shouting and a lot of them start spitting at the Soviet players and it ends in this massive punch up.
另一个非常著名的可能是……冰球。冰球比赛。冰上奇迹。那是什么时候？我想那是 1980 年。那可能是另一个非常著名的冰球比赛——冰上奇迹。晚些时候，那是什么时候？我想那是 1980 年。嗯，所以那是——好吧，那是美国人抵制之前吗？那是莫斯科夏季奥运会之前吗？所以是的，如果我没记错的话，那是 1980 年初的冬季奥运会。如果我记错了，听众会纠正我的。
The Hungarians win 4-0. And who wins? The Hungarians win. And they win the gold medal, I think. But a lot of their players defect, including the guy who was bloodied, Irvin Saddle. He ends up being a water polo coach in California, bizarrely. Wow. So, yeah, so right there you have the absolute... I mean, that's one story.
当然，这是业余比赛，所以在美国队效力的球员不是职业冰球运动员，他们不是来自 NHL（国家冰球联盟）的大明星。苏联人总是赢。1980 年 2 月——制作人正在告诉我们——1980 年 2 月。我为自己感到非常自豪。呃，苏联人——是的，他们总是赢，而这一次他们没有赢。而且这是在这些极其偏袒美国的观众面前，这些业余选手——我想他们基本上是大学生——他们赢了。这是一个令人难以置信的震惊。
Probably the other very famous... The ice hockey. The ice hockey match. The Miracle on Ice. So when is that? That's 1980, I think it is. that probably the other very famous the ice hockey ice hockey match the miracle on ice late when is that that's 1980 i think it is um so that's played okay so that's before the the americans have boycotted is it before the moscow summer games so yes i think it's the beginning of 1980 if i remember right the winter olympics i mean this if i'm wrong listeners will correct me um and of course it's amateur so the people who are playing in the
事实上，那个时刻可能就是你看到——你可以追溯到四年后洛杉矶奥运会精神的时刻，即来自普莱西德湖“冰上奇迹”的、涡轮增压般的美国爱国主义。因为在那里，你突然拥有了——因为当然美国不常有机会与其他国家比赛。
united states team are not professional ice hockey players they're not the big stars from the nhl the soviets always win um and february 1980 producer is telling us february 1980 i feel very proud of myself um uh and the soviets yeah they always win and this time they don't and it's in front of this incredibly partisan american crowd and these amateurs i think they're basically college kids they win and it's this incredible shock um and actually that moment is probably the moment where you see the you know you can trace the l the spirit of the LA Games four years later, that the turbocharged American patriotism from the miracle on ice in Lake Placid, because there you suddenly have, because of course America doesn't get to play other countries.
这也是为什么我认为奥运会在美国远比在英国或欧洲国家更重要的原因之一，因为美国人在国际体育比赛中不常有机会与其他国家比赛。因为当然，在他们自己的运动中，他们是唯一玩这些运动的人。多米尼克，你不能这么说，否则你会惹麻烦的。好吧，其他人确实打篮球，好吧。我们有一些篮球狂热分子，上次用疯狂的推文狂轰滥炸了我们。但美国球队不常与国际球队比赛，对吧？
This is one reason I think why the Olympics matter in America far more than they do in, let's say, Britain or European countries, because Americans don't get to play other countries very often in international sport. Because, of course, their own sports, they're the only people that play them. Dominic, you're not allowed to say that or you'll get in trouble. Well, other people do play basketball, fine. We've got the basketball-ophiles who bombarded us with demented tweets last time. But American teams don't play international teams, do they?
我的意思是，打篮球时经常这样。所以这就是为什么——好吧，他们偶尔确实在足球比赛中对阵伊朗。他们确实对阵过。是的，他们确实对阵过。所以他们赢了。总之，这一切都是……
I mean, in basketball very often. So that's why... Well, they do occasionally play Iran at football. They do. They do. Yes, they do. So they won out. Anyway, so this is all...
是的，不，我明白这一点。有点语无伦次了。所以谈到冷战主题，接着你就有莫斯科 1980 年奥运会。莫斯科 1980 年奥运会是——抵制活动明显开始的地方。你知道最奇怪的是什么，汤姆，这是吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）的怪招。你知道的，俄罗斯人入侵了阿富汗。但这是——我的意思是，我这么说并不是作为一个——我的意思是，我不是什么冷战鸽派之类的人。但我的意思是，卡特抵制莫斯科奥运会实际上是一种完全过度的反应。
Yeah, no, I get that. Bit of a sort of rambling. So on the Cold War theme, so then you've got Moscow 1980. And Moscow 1980 is where it becomes... where the boycotts obviously start. And you know the weird thing about that, Tom, is this is Jimmy Carter's wheeze. You know, the Russians have invaded Afghanistan. But it was, I mean, I'm not saying this as a sort of, I mean, I'm not a sort of Cold War dove or anything. But I mean, it was a complete overreaction by Carter
这纯粹是为了显得强硬吗？我认为很大程度上是为了显得强硬。他当时被视为软弱。对阵罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）的选举即将来临，当时里根……我的意思是，阿富汗当时已经是苏联的傀儡国。所以围绕苏联入侵阿富汗的那些言论其实是被相当夸大了。
to boycott the Moscow Games, actually. Was it for kind of to look strong? I think a lot of it was to look strong. He was perceived as weak. The election was coming against Ronald Reagan when Reagan was banned. I mean, Afghanistan was already a Soviet client state. So the sort of rhetoric around the Soviet invasion
这就是为什么——比如英国去了吗？哦，那是撒切尔夫人——她对英国运动员施加了巨大的压力，不让他们去。但她——有一个——（你知道的）政治不应该干涉体育，英国政府在法律上无法阻止他们去。他们提出了——我的意思是，人们，报纸上引起了巨大的轩然大波。我的意思是，我在我关于英国系列的最新一本书中写过这个。回顾这段历史绝对令人着迷。
of Afghanistan was pretty inflated actually and and is that why um say britain went well that's just thatcher um put enormous pressure on the british athletes not to go but she there was a you know politics doesn't get involved with sport the british government couldn't legally prevent them from going. They put it, I mean, people, there was enormous furore in the newspapers. I mean, I've written about this in my last, most recent book in my series on Britain. And it's absolutely fascinating going through.
但当时确实有一种真正的辩论。因此，即使在非常反共的报纸上，比如《泰晤士报》或《每日快报》，它们的读者来信专栏、社论栏目，也经常发表赞成和反对的观点，人们会——特别是体育记者，他们坚决认为不让运动员去是不公平的。运动员自己通常是想去的。
But there was a real sense of debate, actually. So even in very sort of anti-communist newspapers, the Times, let's say, or the Daily Express, the letters pages, the editorial columns, they would often give views for and against and people would be the sports journalists in particular were adamant that it would be really unfair in the athletes not to go and the athletes themselves generally wanted to go um i think daily thompson was asked about it said he didn't give a damn about that was his they were his words he was great he said i don't give a damn about that was his they were his words he was great he said i don't give a damn
我想当 Daley Thompson 被问及此事时，他说他一点也不在乎——那是他的原话。他很棒，他说：“我才不在乎俄罗斯入侵阿富汗呢，我要去拿金牌。”有一次，外交部国务大臣道格拉斯·赫德（Douglas Hurd）去会见彼得·科（Peter Coe，塞巴斯蒂安·科的教练），并试图说服他塞巴斯蒂安·科不应该去莫斯科。彼得·科的反应就像是：“你知道的，我们要去。”不去的人——有趣且好笑的是——不去的人恰恰是那些你认为最右翼的人，因为他们上过私立学校。所以马术运动员没有去，所以没有盛装舞步。赛艇界也拒绝去莫斯科。但其他所有人都去了。
about the russian invasion of afghanistan i'm going to get the wing gold um at one point douglas heard who was minister of state at the foreign office he goes for a meeting with peter ko sebastian ko's trainer and tries to persuade him that seb shouldn't go to moscow and peter goes like you know we're going um the people who don't go are amusingly and entertainingly the people who who don't go who are the people who precisely the people who you would assume would be the most right wing because they have gone to private schools so the equestrians don't go um so no dressage there's no dressageage. And the yachting fraternity refused to go to Moscow. But everybody else goes.
显然，我的意思是，英国的运势——顺便说一句，英国在 70 年代的奥运会上表现糟糕透顶。我们稍微从谷底爬了起来。因为那是史蒂夫……史蒂夫·奥韦特（Steve Ovett）和塞巴斯蒂安·科（Sebastian Coe）。他们在各自的专项中击败了对方。Daley Thompson 在十项全能中赢得金牌，艾伦·韦尔斯（Alan Wells）在 100 米跑中赢得金牌。
And obviously, I mean, British fortunes, by the way, Britain had performed abysmally in the Olympics in the 70s. And we sort of clambered a little bit off the canvas. Because that's the Steve... Yvette and Sebastian Coe. They beat each other at each other's specialism. Daley Thompson wins gold in the decathlon, and Alan Wells wins gold in the 100 metres.
所以对英国来说，这是一次巨大的欢呼，因为西德人不在。美国人、加拿大人和日本人都不在。但当他们所有人回到家时，他们最初并没有获得勋章。撒切尔夫人没有推荐他们获得勋章。事实上，塞巴斯蒂安·科最后成了保守党议员，对吧？是的，他确实是。威廉·黑格（William Hague）的柔道教练——当威廉·黑格戴着写有“黑格”字样的棒球帽顺着激流勇进滑水道滑下去时——正如威廉·黑格的狂热粉丝所知，那是他在 20世纪 90 年代成为保守党领袖后的一场灾难性的照片拍摄活动——他顺着激流勇进滑水道滑下去，塞巴斯蒂安·科就紧随其后。而激流勇进滑水道确实指出了这一点——不管怎样！但听着，我们记住塞巴斯蒂安·科是因为所有错误的原因：我们记住他是因为他的奥运金牌，而不是因为激流勇进滑水道，这不对。好吧，但只要我们坚持谈论冷战，而不是威廉·黑格的职业生涯——这两者同样重要——
So for Britain, this is a great sort of hurrah, hurrah, because the West Germans aren't there. The Americans and the Canadians and the Japanese aren't there. But when they all come home, they don't get decorated initially mrs thatcher does not recommend them for medals and actually ko ends up a tory mp right he does he does um william haig's judo instructor he well when william haig goes down the log flume wearing his baseball cap says haig on it uh as aficionados of william haig will know that this disastrous photo opportunity after he became tory leader in the 1990s he goes down the log flume sebastian
苏联对美国的反应是——太荒谬了。他们随后抵制了洛杉矶奥运会。不，但——但他们最初的计划是把美国人打得落花流水，所以他们开始注入更多的兴奋剂、进行更多的训练。是的，那是他们的计划。正如你所能看出的，汤姆对这一切了如指掌。我对此了如指掌。好吧，这是你的时期。我不知道——我的意思是斯巴达人，我会没问题的。但——这是一场迟到的抵制，对吧？我没有关注——不管怎样，这是一个高质量的播客。所以美国人——好吧，发生的事情是，莫斯科是一届糟糕的奥运会。莫斯科非常单调乏味，
co is just behind him and the log flume really pointed out is it every anyway but listen we remember sebastian co for all the wrong things they remember him for the olympic golds but not for the log flume and it's not right okay but just just sticking to the uh the cold war rather than to the career of william haig they both are equally important yeah um the the soviets response to the american yeah ridiculous they then boycott la no but no but but their initial plan is to wipe the floor with the americans so they start pumping in more drugs more training yes yeah that's that's their plan tom's all over this as you can tell i'm all over it well this is your period i don't know i mean the spartans i'll be fine but but it's it's a late boycott is it i
安保令人窒息，城市的很大一部分被疏散了，基本上孩子们都被带离了莫斯科。外国记者团基本上写信回国说这太糟糕了，因为他们中的许多人——别忘了，有很多人——你知道的，在 20 世纪 60 年代和 70 年代，人们通常不会去莫斯科。所以所有这些平时报道体育的人——所以他们把时间花在水晶宫（Crystal Palace）观看稍微有点冷门的田径赛事——他们去了莫斯科，写出的稿件发表在西方报纸上，上面写着：“天哪，这个地方太糟糕了。你知道的，这就是我们对‘第三罗马’的印象，这个超级大国的首都。”
haven't i haven't followed anyway this is quality podcast so then the american well what happens is moscow is a terrible games moscow is very drab um the security is suffocating a lot of the city has been evacuated so basically children have been taken out of moscow the foreign press corps basically write home and say this is awful because a lot of them for the don't forget there's a lot of people who you you know, people don't go to Moscow by and large in the 1960s and 70s. So all these people who normally report on sport, so they spend their time at Crystal Palace watching kind of slightly obscure athletics events. They go to Moscow and they're writing copy that's appearing in Western newspapers saying, God, this place is awful. You know, it's this sort of this image that we have of the third Rome, you know, the capital of this superpower.
但在 70 年代，每个人都认为它代表了现代性。所以那种我们——我是在这种印象中长大的——认为莫斯科充满了排队和破败。是的，这难道是记者们造成的吗？我认为很大程度上确实是 1980 年造成的，因为这些人是——
But in the 70s, everybody thinks represents modernity. So the idea that we have, you know, that I remember growing up with, that Moscow is kind of cues and shabbiness. Yeah. Does that come from the journalists? A lot of it, I think, does come from 1980 because these are people who are,
人们一直有一种感觉，认为它是一座令人望而生畏的黑暗堡垒，但那种“它究竟有多糟糕”的感觉，我认为很大程度上确实源于 1980 年的奥运会，特别是在英国报纸上。并且那种感觉是——哦，事实上，因为在 70 年代关于冷战的讨论中，有很大一部分都在说俄罗斯人正在获胜，
there'd always been a sense of sort of it being a forbidding sort of dark citadel, but the sort of sense of just how awful it is. A lot of that, I think, does come from the 1980 game, certainly in the British papers. And the sense that it's, oh, actually, because so much in the 70s of the talk about the Cold War had been that the Russians were winning
因为当然美国在越南受辱了，发生了水门事件，俄罗斯人正在渗透非洲等等。然后人们去了莫斯科奥运会，他们觉得：“哦，天哪，这实际上太糟糕了。”所以这很有趣，因为如果这样的话，这就是极权主义奥运会失败、走向错误方向的一个例子。
because, of course, America's been humiliated in Vietnam. They've been Watergate. The Russians are penetrating Africa and so on. And then people go to the Moscow Games. They're like, oh, God, this is actually terrible. So that's interesting because that, in which case, that's an example of totalitarian Olympics not working. Gone wrong.
是的，完全正确。我认为这绝对正确。我认为没有人从莫斯科回到家后会说：“哦，苏联人就像我想象的那么强大。”我认为他们回家后，完全表达的是截然相反的看法。当然，这很好地为洛杉矶奥运会做好了铺垫，洛杉矶奥运会简直就是里根时代美国的终极体现。是的，确实是。
Yeah, exactly right. i think that's exactly right i don't think anyone comes home from moscow and says oh the soviets are just as powerful as i had imagined they were i think they come home and completely the opposite expression and that of course nicely tees up los angeles which is just the ultimate expression of kind of reagan america yeah it is yeah um so immense corporate you know that's stars and stripes corporate sponsorship take turned up to 11 um you know it's it's happening in california and sunshine the american news media goes completely berserk and basically doesn't mention the fact that anybody else is participating in the games at all which really shocks a lot of even sympathetic kind of british
巨大的企业赞助——你知道的，那是“星条旗”式的企业赞助，被开到了 11 级（开到极致）。你知道的，它发生在阳光灿烂的加利福尼亚，美国新闻媒体彻底疯狂了，基本上完全不提还有其他任何人在参加奥运会，这真的让许多甚至富有同情心的英国
and german and so on observers because they can't believe how how ultra patriotic the americans are about their 84 games it's carl lewis's games and it's also the games at which um daily thompson great hero of mine perhaps slightly disgraces himself by baiting carl lewis about the possibility that carl lewis is gay do you remember that yeah i do so he went he walks around with a t-shirt on saying um is the world's second best athlete gay and when people ask him about to the press conference he says oh in england gay means happy yeah i do maybe remember but carl lewis carl lewis i mean he was photographed wearing stilettos wasn't he was he i don't know where did you hear that from daily thompson probably i don't know i think we should i think we should have um we should have a break here i'm just going to check
和德国等地的观察家感到震惊，因为他们简直不敢相信美国人对他们的 84 年奥运会表现得如此超级爱国。这是卡尔·刘易斯（Carl Lewis）的奥运会，这也是一届这样的奥运会：Daley Thompson——我的伟大英雄——可能稍微有点出丑了，他通过嘲笑卡尔·刘易斯可能是同性恋来取笑卡尔·刘易斯。你还记得吗？是的，我记得。所以他穿着一件T恤到处走，上面写着：“世界上第二优秀的运动员是同性恋吗？”当记者在新闻发布会上问他时，他说：“哦，在英国，同性恋（gay）意味着快乐。”是的，我可能记得。但是卡尔·刘易斯——卡尔·刘易斯，我的意思是，他被拍到穿着细高跟鞋，不是吗？是吗？我不知道你从哪里听说的？大概是 Daley Thompson 说的吧。我不知道。我想我们应该——我想我们应该在这里休息一下。我只是要去核实
that to make sure that i haven't i think it'd be great if this i mean if this podcast is to be cancelled i think being cancelled because you've slandered Carl Lewis. Well, it's not a slander to West Littles. I think he wants the West Littles. I think he wants the West Littles. That's fine. But I just want to make sure that's right. So let's have a break.
这一点，以确保我没有——我认为如果这个播客要被取消的话，因为你诽谤了卡尔·刘易斯而被取消，那就太棒了。好吧，这不算诽谤 West Littles（卡尔·刘易斯）。我想他想要 West Littles。我想他想要。这没问题。但我只是想确保这是对的。所以我们休息一下吧。
I will go and check that. The Davey Thompson of historical podcasting, Tom Holland. And I think that when we come back, we should look at TV. Well, we've got TV, but we've also got some very dark chapters we haven't talked about mexico and munich in particular okay so let's look at that when we come back okay all right bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
我去查证一下。历史播客界的 Daley Thompson——汤姆·霍兰。我想当我们回来时，我们应该看看电视。好吧，我们有电视，但我们也有一些非常黑暗的篇章我们还没聊过，特别是墨西哥和慕尼黑。好的，那我们回来时再聊这个。好的，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》。这里有你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history uh tom holland i believe you have something you want to say to the lawyers i do okay so yes um that subliminal memory that was flashing around in my mind of of carl lewis in stilettos is right so i i it's not a false memory it was part of an advertising campaign by the italian tire company pirelli and i'm reading this off the internet um it was taken
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。汤姆·霍兰，我相信你有什么话想对律师说。我确实有。好的，所以，是的——我脑海中一闪而过的那个关于卡尔·刘易斯穿细高跟鞋的潜意识记忆是真的。所以，这不是虚假的记忆，它是意大利轮胎公司倍耐力（Pirelli）广告活动的一部分。我这是在从互联网上读出来的——它是由
by american celebrity photographer annie leibovitz and it showed him wearing a pair of red stiletto heels okay so i was right and i guess you may be making play with the maybe no i don't think carl lewis is that i don't think he's i don't see that knowing i'm not sure he's that ironic okay um i mean i remember do you remember the uh ben johnson carl lewis that was titanic when i was at school i mean everybody so wasn't it that was sold everybody had a preference either lewis or johnson i remember johnson winning and being delighted because i wanted him to win and then and then yeah the and that's probably it's up there with so we should say for people who don't know that i mean ben johnson was absolutely up to his eyeballs in yeah which
美国名人摄影师安妮·莱博维茨（Annie Leibovitz）拍摄的，照片显示他穿着一双红色的细高跟鞋。好吧，我是对的。我猜你可能会借此发挥……也许没有，我不认为卡尔·刘易斯是那样——我不认为他是……我不觉得这是开玩笑。我不确定他是那么具有讽刺意味的人。好吧。我的意思是，我记得——你还记得本·约翰逊（Ben Johnson）对阵卡尔·刘易斯吗？我在上学的时候，那简直是轰动一时。我的意思是，每个人——难道不是吗？那是轰动一时的。每个人都有自己的偏好，要么选刘易斯，要么选约翰逊。我记得约翰逊赢了，我很高兴，因为我希望他赢。然后——然后，是的，那可能——我们应该对那些不知道的人说，本·约翰逊当时完全深陷其中，
i think frankly i'm not defending ben johnson all of it was true pretty generally um for a lot of athletes not all of them maybe but for a lot of athletes in the 70s and in the 80s well 90s actually um is this is this legally well i didn't i said not all of them so if you're listening to this and you're an olympic athlete i don't mean the 70s 80s and i definitely don't please don't sue us i mean the other competitors i mean the ones who did yeah but obviously at that point by the Ben Johnson scandal was the biggest scandal probably in the biggest doping scandal in Olympic history and you know well has meant that ever apart from Thomas Hicks in the the Strictly yeah and the egg whites and the
坦率地说，我认为我并不是在为本·约翰逊辩护，这一切对许多运动员来说都是普遍存在的——也许不是所有人，但对于 70 年代和 80 年代——好吧，实际上还有 90 年代——的许多运动员来说……这是在法律上……好吧，我说的是“不是所有人”。所以如果你在听这个节目，而且你是一名奥运会运动员，我指的不是 70 年代和 80 年代，我绝对不是这个意思，请不要起诉我们！我的意思是其他竞争对手，我是指那些确实——但很明显，当时本·约翰逊丑闻是奥运会历史上最大的丑闻，可能是最大的兴奋剂丑闻，你知道的——除了托马斯·希克斯（Thomas Hicks）在严格的意义上——还有生鸡蛋和
brand yes well um yeah that's like the asterix in the olympic games taking that's at the time but but i mean apart from i mean the ben johnson scandal is a sort of supposedly a dark chapter in the history of the olympics but but i mean it isn't really compared with some of the dark chapters brilliant segue so yeah i thought brilliantly i thought that was superb i'm glad you like that i was like dressage. Even as I was doing it. The judges would give you 10 points for that. Had I been a competitor in 1980, I wouldn't have had the chance
白兰地——是的。好吧，嗯，是的，就像奥运会上的星号一样，当时的情况就是这样。但是，我的意思是——除了本·约翰逊丑闻被认为是奥运会历史上一个黑暗的篇章之外，但我的意思是，与一些黑暗的篇章相比，这其实不算什么。精彩的衔接！是的，我想这真是太精彩了。我很高兴你喜欢这样。我当时就想，就像盛装舞步一样。即使我在做这件事时，裁判也会给你打 10 分。如果我是 1980 年的参赛选手，我根本没有机会
to do that in Moscow. That was magnificent. You've podiumed with that. Thank you. So the dark moments. So I think there are three games in a row pretty much that are bad. The least bad of them is the last one, which is Montreal, and that's bad just for ludicrous overspending.
在莫斯科这样做。太棒了。你凭这个登上领奖台了。谢谢。所以，黑暗的时刻。所以我想基本上有连续三届奥运会是不好的。其中最不坏的是最后一届，也就是蒙特利尔奥运会，而那届不好纯粹是因为荒谬的超支。
So in that one, Montreal in 1976, Canadian listeners, I know we have some Canadian listeners, and they will definitely remember this, the costs overrun by 720%. Montreal went a billion dollars into debt, and they didn't pay off the debt for the stadium until 2006 I mean just mind-boggling um and you know about the the mayor Jean Drapeau yes the mayor so he said a city can no more lose money on the Olympics than a man can have a baby
所以在那一届——1976 年的蒙特利尔奥运会上，加拿大听众——我知道我们有一些加拿大听众，他们绝对会记得这一点——成本超支了 720%。蒙特利尔背负了 10 亿美元的债务，直到 2006 年他们才还清体育场的债务。我的意思是，简直令人匪夷所思。而且你知道关于市长让·德拉波（Jean Drapeau）的事吗？是的，这位市长。所以他说：“城市在奥运会上亏钱的概率，和一个男人能生孩子一样大。”
right well and couldn't say that now he also um he he basically compared the uh the olympic stadium in montreal to the acropolis but it still doesn't work the olympic stadium in montreal has never worked it has this fancy retracting roof they've had to repair well so i put this out i i put this out on twitter and uh canadian journalist james many replied if memory serves the roof of the acropolis was blown to bits after the ottomans used it as an ammunition dump i think it was actually the venetians wasn't it um but anyway the point is is accurate our roof fell in because of snow yeah so there was incredibly crooked the main construction union had links to organized crime and basically it's bankrupted effectively bankrupted montreal and the city took decades and decades to recover. So that's bad. So that's bad, but not as bad as obviously the two previous games.
好吧，现在可不能这么说了。他还——他基本上把蒙特利尔的奥林匹克体育场比作雅典卫城。但它至今仍然不管用。蒙特利尔的奥林匹克体育场从来就没有管用过。它有那个华丽的可伸缩屋顶，他们不得不修理——所以我把这个发到推特上，加拿大记者詹姆斯·曼尼（James Many）回复说：“如果没记错的话，雅典卫城的屋顶在奥斯曼人将其用作弹药库后被炸得粉碎。”我想那其实是威尼斯人干的，对吧？不过，重点是准确的：我们的屋顶是因为积雪而塌的。是的。所以极其腐败，主要的建筑工会与有组织犯罪有联系。基本上，这让蒙特利尔破产了——实际上让蒙特利尔破产了，这座城市花了整整几十年的时间才恢复过来。所以这很糟糕。这很糟糕，但显然没有前两届奥运会那么糟糕。
So Mexico, 1968. Mexico is a troubled country in the late 60s, huge student protests, a lot of police repression. And just before the games start, the Mexican government basically shoots and kills between that probably between three and four hundred student protesters in the center of mexico city and the people who are most responsible for doing this are a special battalion called the olympia battalion of the mexican security forces who wear special they were in plain clothes they wear white
所以，1968 年的墨西哥。墨西哥在 60 年代末是一个动荡的国家，有巨大的学生抗议活动，还有大量的警察镇压。就在奥运会开始前，墨西哥政府基本上在墨西哥城中心枪杀并杀害了三到四百名学生抗议者。对此负有最大责任的是墨西哥安全部队中一个名为“奥林匹亚营”（Olympia Battalion）的特殊营。他们穿着特殊的——他们穿便服，戴着白手套，
gloves so that the other police went far in them, they were in plain clothes, they wear white gloves, so that the other police weren't firing them, and they set up machine guns and basically machine gunned the crowds. That's not good preparation. And there's a lot of talk about, you know, can the Games go ahead under these circumstances? And the IOC president, who's an American, called Avery Brundage. Brundage was a terrible man. He was the man who had insisted that the Americans not boycott the Berlin Games in 1936.
这样其他警察就不会向他们开枪。他们穿便服，戴着白手套，这样其他警察就不会向他们开枪。他们架起机枪，基本上对人群进行了机枪扫射。这不是什么好准备。当时有很多关于“在這種情况下奥运会还能不能继续举行”的讨论。而国际奥委会主席是一个名叫艾弗里·布伦戴奇（Avery Brundage）的美国人。布伦戴奇是个糟糕透顶的人。他就是那个在 1936 年坚决主张美国不应该抵制柏林奥运会的人。
He had a history of anti-Semitism and racist remarks and stuff. Brundage is asked, did you see this? And he says, no, I was at the ballet. So the Mexican Games go ahead. And then, of course, the Mexican Games... So this guy Brundage, that's the context for the really famous image from the Mexican games. The Black Power salute.
他有反犹太主义和发表种族主义言论的历史。有人问布伦戴奇：“你看到这个了吗？”他说：“没有，我在看芭蕾舞。”所以墨西哥奥运会照常举行了。然后，当然，墨西哥奥运会——所以这个叫布伦戴奇的家伙，这就是墨西哥奥运会上那张真正著名的照片的背景：黑人权力的敬礼。
The Black Power salute. Yeah, Tommy Smith and John Carlos. So that, again, is a terrible story. So they do the Black Power salute. And, of course, they do it in the context. Martin Luther King and Robert Kennedy were assassinated in 1968 in America. America is in the Vietnam War. It is wracked by protests.
黑人权力敬礼。对，托米·史密斯和约翰·卡洛斯。所以，这也是一个糟糕的故事。他们行了黑人权力敬礼。当然，他们是在特定的背景下这么做的。1968年，马丁·路德·金和罗伯特·肯尼迪在美国被暗杀。美国正深陷越南战争，抗议活动此起彼伏。
The civil rights movement, the optimism is beginning to leak away. There have been race riots. It's all very troubled. And actually, against that background, merely doing a salute and a glove during the playing of your anthem doesn't really seem like such an incendiary.
民权运动的乐观情绪开始消逝。发生了种族骚乱。局势非常动荡。事实上，在这种背景下，仅仅在演奏国歌时行一个礼、戴一只手套，似乎并不算是什么多么煽动性的举动。
So Tommy Smith wins. It's 200 metres, right? I think it's 200 metres. There are three of them on the podium. John Carlos comes third and there's an Australian who comes second and he joins in. Well, he wears a badge. Peter Norman. He wears it.
于是托米·史密斯赢了。那是200米赛跑，对吧？我想是200米。领奖台上有三个人。约翰·卡洛斯得了第三名，还有一个澳大利亚人得了第二名，他也加入了进来。嗯，他戴了一个徽章。彼得·诺曼。他戴着它。
OK. It's actually a nice story. He is the one who suggests to them about the glove, that they wear a glove each, because tell him they want to do this it's actually a story that reflects really well on all three of them they say to him we we feel really strongly about this we want to do this protest and they say to him do you believe in god and he says yes because he's a member of the salvation army salvation army background and and and they say well that's why we want to do it and he says oh i'll support you you know and um they are basically banned from the olympics forever by avery brundage american head of the ioc and peter norman there's a lot of controversy about this in
好的。这其实是个不错的赤字。是他建议他们戴手套的，每人戴一只，因为告诉他他们想这么做——这其实是一个对他们三个人都很有正面意义的故事，他们对他说，我们对这件事感同身受，我们想要进行这场抗议，他们对他说，你信仰上帝吗？他说信仰，因为他是救世军成员，有救世军的背景，他们说，好吧，这就是我们想这么做的原因，然后他说，哦，我会支持你们的，你知道的，然后……基本上他们被国际奥委会的美国负责人艾弗里·布伦戴奇永远禁止参加奥运会了，彼得·诺曼……关于这件事在澳大利亚有很多争议，
australia whether it's for sporting reasons or for other reasons but he's not and he doesn't get into the australian team for the next Olympics. A lot of people have always thought that was because he was basically blacklisted because he had shown support for these two guys. So that's a very, I mean, that is the most famous image by far, one of the most famous images in Olympic history, but it's one from which the Olympic movement emerges with no credit whatsoever, I would say.
不知道是因为竞技原因还是其他原因，但他没有入选下一届奥运会的澳大利亚代表队。许多人一直认为，那是因为他支持了这两个人，所以基本上被列入了黑名单。所以这是一个……我的意思是，这是迄今为止最著名的画面，奥运会历史上最著名的画面之一，但我可以说，奥林匹克运动在这件事上没有赢得任何赞誉。
Yeah, there's a kind of sense of slight sense of, well, I mean, considerable sense of moral bankruptcy. Yeah. Hanging over the Olympics throughout the 70s and 80s. Well, Munich is a shocking. And this is the worst. Yeah. It's a terrible story, really.
对，有一种……微微的感觉，好吧，我的意思是，相当强烈的道德破产感。对。这种阴影笼罩了整个70和80年代的奥运会。慕尼黑事件是一场灾难。这也是最糟糕的。对。这真是一个糟糕的故事。
So for listeners, most listeners will know this story. But for those who don't, Septemberember the 5th in munich in west germany um it's germany's first chance to host the olympics after 1936 that matters enormously to the germans um that they present this sort of new face of germany to the world and um eight members of the palestinian black september organization they invade the olympic village they take uh 11 israeli athletes and officials hostage right at the beginning they kill two of them um a wrestling coach and a wrestler uh they kill and torture them really horribly i mean it's a terrible story um they
所以对于听众来说，大多数听众都会知道这个故事。但对于那些不知道的人来说，9月5日在西德的慕尼黑，这是德国自1936年以来第一次有机会举办奥运会，这对外德国人来说至关重要，他们向世界展示德国的新面貌，然后，巴勒斯坦“黑色九月”组织的八名成员入侵了奥运村，在刚开始时绑架了11名以色列运动员和官员，他们杀害了其中两人，一名摔跤教练和一名摔跤手，他们残忍地杀害并虐待了他们，我的意思是，这是一个糟糕的故事……他们
and so this is in the context of the incredible you know the anti-semitism that had stayed in the 36 games yeah as well it could so from the perspective of the olympics it could not be a worse story right i mean because it's a reminder you can't help think back to 1936 yeah um but you know the the sort of adage about politics and sport don't mix is comprehensively demolished by this by this incident the terrorists then go with the hostages to um a military airport and there the the Germans launch this disastrous botched operation to rescue the hostages, which basically ends up with everybody being killed.
所以这是在令人难以置信的背景下发生的，你知道的，36年奥运会遗留的反犹太主义，对吧，也是如此。所以从奥运会的角度来看，这不可能是一个更糟糕的故事了，对吧？我的意思是，因为这是一个提醒，人们不禁会回想起1936年，对吧，但是你知道的，关于政治和体育不能混为一谈的老生常谈被这次事件彻底粉碎了。恐怖分子随后带着人质前往一个军事机场，在那里，德国人发起了这场灾难性的、笨拙的救援人质行动，结果基本上是以所有人丧生告终。
All the hostages are killed. And I think all the hostage takers. And this is the... Some of them get away because then... Yes, of course. Not all the hostage takers. They get hunted down. Right.
所有人都遇害了。所有的人质都遇害了。我想所有的劫持者也是。这就是……有些人逃脱了，因为后来……是的，当然。并非所有的劫持者。他们被追捕了。对。
Israel has this operation wrath of god as it's called mossad there's a brilliant book about this by a guy called i think it's called ronan bergman called rise and kill first or rise and strike first or something which i reviewed a few years ago really riveting read and of course steven spielberg's film munich um it's all about this about the hunt for the for the people who planned it and so on um and again avery brundage is there uh and he says you know the politics and sport can't mix the games will go on so in other words he's perfectly happy to have the games in hitler's um berlin and he thinks the game should continue despite the fact that one of the teams has just seen 11 of its members murdered.
以色列有一个代号为“上帝之怒”的行动，由摩萨德执行。有一本关于这的书写得非常棒，作者好像叫罗纳·伯格曼，书名叫《复仇：以色列摩萨德暗杀行动》或者类似的名称，我几年前写过书评，读起来非常引人入胜。当然，斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的电影《慕尼黑》讲的就是这个，关于对策划者的追捕等等。而且，艾弗里·布伦戴奇又出现了，他说，政治和体育不能混为一谈，比赛将继续进行。换句话说，他非常乐意在希特勒的柏林举办奥运会，他认为尽管其中一个代表团刚刚有11名成员被谋杀，比赛仍应继续。
And you sort of think, well, if he's not going to stop it then or postpone it or do something, would you ever stop it? And I guess his answer would have been no, he never would. So, yeah, that's a... Go on, Tom. I mean, that taint. Berlin Olympics, Munich, the greed, the Cold War rivalries. I mean, I think it is a kind of permanent shadow over any idea that the Olympics are a festival of... I completely agree.
你会想，如果他当时不阻止、不推迟或者做点什么，那他什么时候才会阻止呢？我想他的回答会是“不，他永远不会”。所以，好吧，这是一个……继续吧，汤姆。我的意思是，那种污点。柏林奥运会、慕尼黑奥运会、贪婪、冷战对立。我的意思是，我认为这给“奥运会是……的节日”这一理念投下了永久的阴影。我完全同意。
So when you mentioned in the last podcast, the first one we did on this, on the modern Olympics, about David Goldblatt's book, and I was looking back at David Goldblatt's book, and he wrote an article just before the current Olympics, the Tokyo Olympics, in which he basically argues, he says, you know,
所以当你在上期播客中——我们关于现代奥运会的第一次讨论——提到大卫·戈德布拉特的书时，我翻看了一下大卫·戈德布拉特的书，他在当前奥运会（东京奥运会）开始前不久写了一篇文章，在文中他基本上提出，他说，你知道的，
the Olympics should stop. They should be wound up. And he gives a series of facts, actually, which are, you know, we've seen in our recent sort of lifetimes um los angeles seoul barcelona i mean barcelona is probably the one great success story because it really raised barcelona's reputation massive yeah the city because the city is the star of that right yeah and also catalonia i think a big boost catalan nationalism but also i mean it's the one that after the end of the Cold War, so the old Soviet-American rivalry is slightly put to bed.
奥运会应该停止。它们应该被取消。实际上，他列举了一系列事实，你知道的，我们在最近的记忆中都见证过，洛杉矶、首尔、巴塞罗那——我的意思是，巴塞罗那可能是最伟大的成功故事，因为它真正提升了巴塞罗那的声誉，规模巨大，对吧，因为城市是那届奥运会的明星，对吧，还有加泰罗尼亚，我认为这对加泰罗尼亚民族主义是一个巨大的推动。但同时，这也是冷战结束后的一届，所以旧的苏美对抗稍微被搁置了。
I think that's right, and I think it's probably the least tainted. Yeah. So then you have Atlanta, 1996. I mean, awful, an awful game. It's a pipe bomb attack, but also it should never have been given to Atlanta. Everybody agrees that. The organisation was poor. It was a complete sellout to Coca-Cola, and it should never have been given to Atlanta. Everybody agrees that. The organisation was poor. It was a complete sell-out to Coca-Cola.
我想是的，而且我认为它受到的玷污可能是最少的。对。然后就是1996年亚特兰大奥运会。我的意思是，糟糕透顶的一届奥运会。发生了管状炸弹袭击，而且它根本就不应该交给亚特兰大举办。大家都这么认为。组织工作很糟。这完全是对可口可乐的妥协，根本不应该交给亚特兰大举办。大家都这么认为。组织工作很糟。这完全是对可口可乐的卑躬屈膝。
It should have been Athens. Should because it's centenary. I think the Sydney games are pretty good. But then Athens is... I mean, it's a financial disaster, isn't it? Just before the financial crisis as well. You think what happened to Greece just a few years later that they've blown all this money on the games it's kind of lent and car i mean kind of like the the ioc are like dealers they're like the kind of
本来应该是雅典。本该如此，因为那是百年华诞。我认为悉尼奥运会相当不错。但雅典……我的意思是，这是一场财务灾难，对吧？而且就发生在金融危机之前不久。你想想几年后希腊发生了什么，他们把所有的钱都挥霍在奥运会上，这就好像是借贷和汽车……我的意思是，国际奥委会就像是毒贩，就像那种
mafia encouraging people to get into gambling debt absolutely so that then they can take over their sports shop or something i mean that's what it felt like with athens yeah that greece got horribly stiffed basically i mean the beijing games were obviously an advert for the chinese regime no doubt no one would sort of dispute that the london games a magnificent monument to blairism well we loved i mean everybody in britain loved the london games because we did really well because we made it we like the queen or going to be a to a helicopter was in it um but it was very expensive and it left it didn't increase participation sport which everybody claimed it would and it left london with i'm not going to say the olympic park is a white elephant but it is a bit of a white elephant um you know there's there's good news for west ham
鼓励人们陷入债务泥潭的黑帮，绝对是这样，这样他们就可以接管人家的体育用品商店什么的。感觉雅典奥运会就是这样，希腊基本上被狠狠地坑了一把。我的意思是，北京奥运会显然是为中国政权做的一次宣传，毫无疑问，没有人会对此产生异议。伦敦奥运会是布莱尔主义的一座宏伟纪念碑。嗯，我们喜欢——英国的每个人都喜欢伦敦奥运会，因为我们表现得很好，因为我们成功了，我们喜欢女王假装去坐直升机……但它非常昂贵，而且它并没有像所有人宣称的那样提高大众对体育的参与度，它给伦敦留下的……我不是说奥林匹克公园是个大白象工程，但它确实有点像个大白象工程……你知道的，对西汉姆联队来说是个好消息，
right yeah it's yeah it's not as much of a wise elephant as the Montrealers. Yeah, if you're a hammer. Though they hate their new stadium. They can't stand their new stadium. Everyone's unhappy. Yeah. And then what was the last one? Rio.
对吧，是的，它……是的，它不像蒙特利尔的场馆那样是个典型的大白象。是的，如果你是铁锤帮的球迷的话。尽管他们讨厌他们的新体育场。他们简直无法忍受他们的新体育场。每个人都不高兴。对。然后最后一届是什么？里约。
I mean, Rio, terrible story. You know, they didn't... Just reading here from David Goldblatt's article, Rio did not build a single community sporting facility on the back of these Olympic Games. And they moved, they forced out 60,000 people to move out of their homes to make way for Olympic infrastructure.
我的意思是，里约，糟糕的故事。你知道，他们没有……我刚刚在这里读到大卫·戈德布拉特的文章，里约没有因为举办这届奥运会而建设哪怕一个社区体育设施。他们强迫6万名居民搬离家园，以为奥运基础设施让路。
I mean, that's kind of, I think that's pretty indefensible, actually. So these, I mean, the stats are extraordinary. Goldblatt says, no modern games with the exception of Barcelona has ever raised a host city's rate of economic growth, level of skills and employment, tourist income or productivity.
我的意思是，这简直……我认为这实在是毫无辩解的余地。所以，这些数据太惊人了。戈德布拉特说，除了巴塞罗那例外，没有任何一届现代奥运会能够真正提高主办城市的经济增长率、技能和就业水平、旅游收入或生产力。
It's a complete myth that they raised the level of sporting participation in their country. Actually, lots of people watch the Olympics on TV, but they don't then emulate the... I mean, that's the sort of claim that these people... You know, Olympians... I mean, I admire these athletes tremendously who've dedicated their lives to the pursuit of glory and all the rest of it. But the idea that they inspire others is dubious at best.
这完全是个神话，说什么它们提高了他们国家对体育的参与度。事实上，很多人在电视上观看奥运会，但他们并不会因此去效仿……我的意思是，这就是那些人宣称的……你知道的，奥运选手……我的意思是，我非常钦佩这些将一生奉献给追求荣耀等一切的运动员。但他们能激励其他人的说法充其量也是值得怀疑的。
I mean, they may inspire some. Kid in the ghetto, dreaming of dressage. That's always. Yeah. I mean, who didn't grow up in a slum dreaming of synchronized swimming? That's always the claim isn't it but um i think the truth of it is a lot has always been much darker and um and we shouldn't kid i think it has right from the beginning because you think about all the you know the human zoos yeah and all that stuff it's kind of monstrous really um so this is all very bleak isn't it and if it's not bleak enough i'll tell you this his there's an extraordinary story about a a japanese i came across a japanese
我的意思是，他们或许能激励某些人。贫民窟里梦想着盛装舞步的孩子。总是这样。对。我的意思是，谁不是在贫民窟里长大的却梦想着花样游泳呢？这总是他们的说辞，不是吗？但是……我认为事实的真相是，很多事情一直以来都黑暗得多，而且……我们不应该自欺欺人，我认为从一开始就是这样，因为你想想所有那些……你知道的人类动物园，对吧，以及所有这些东西，简直太骇人听闻了。所以，这一切都非常惨淡，不是吗？如果这还不够惨淡，我再告诉你这个，有一个非凡的故事，关于一个日本……我遇到过一个日本
marathon runner called kokichi subayara i'm sorry if i've pronounced that wrong oh is this the is this the one in so he's a tokyo or stockholm it's a tokyo i think it is 64 um but it might be the one you're thinking of so he comes third in the marathon. He'd hoped to win. And he ends up walking. You know, he's shut up. I mean, God, he's been going for 26 miles. It's fair enough.
马拉松运动员，名叫圆谷幸吉，如果我发音错了的话请原谅我。哦，这是那个在……所以他是东京还是斯德哥尔摩？我想是东京，64年，但也有可能是你想的那一个。他在马拉松比赛中获得第三名。他本来希望夺冠的。最后他只能步行。你知道的，他筋疲力尽了。上帝啊，他已经跑了26英里了。这很正常。
He basically stumbles across the line in front of his home crowd, and he's very disappointed. And he says, I have committed an inexcusable blunder in front of the Japanese people. I have to make amends by running and hearing the anthem in our next Olympics. So for the next three years, this poor guy trains like a demon to get into the next Olympics when he can redeem,
他基本上是踉踉跄跄地在主场观众面前冲过终点线，他感到非常失望。他说：“我在日本人民面前犯下了不可饶恕的重大失误。我必须通过在下一届奥运会上跑步并聆听国歌来赎罪。”因此，在接下来的三年里，这个可怜家伙像疯了一样训练，为了能参加下一届奥运会，在那里他可以挽回
as he sees it, the shame of having finished third in front of his home crowd. He has a back injury just before the Olympics, so he can't go. So do you know what he does i mean you can probably guess he leaves himself yeah he kills himself yeah okay so yeah that is a that is a downer but there's a slightly more inspiring one which i because i think it would be it would be remiss to dwell just on the dark side because clearly there is a kind of incredible
在他看来，在主场观众面前获得第三名是奇耻大辱。就在奥运会开始前不久，他的背部受伤了，所以他去不了了。所以你知道他做了什么吗？我的意思是，你大概能猜到。他抛弃了自己……对，他自杀了。对，好吧，所以……这是一个相当沉重的话题，但还有一个稍微鼓舞人心一点的故事，因为我觉得，如果只沉溺于黑暗面未免太失职了，因为显然有一种不可思议的
inspiration yeah um people watch it because they find it moving and inspiring to be honest i'm a complete hypocrite because when we win when the commentator says dominic dominic when the commentator says your your your columns for the daily mail i know there was evidence for your when the commentator says oh this lad from hunstanton his family watching back home i mean i'm in kind of floods of tears it's it's i'm a pitiful figure okay so this anecdote i'm about to tell is going to be a terrible anecdote because i can't really remember it okay and i was i was told it years ago by i think david owen great sports journalist coverage not the sdp not the sdp no no the sports editor of the ft okay and
鼓舞人心的力量，对吧？人们观看比赛是因为他们觉得这感人又催人奋进。老实说，我完全是个伪君子，因为当我们获胜时，当评论员说——多米尼克，多米尼克，当评论员说你的……你为《每日邮报》写的专栏……我知道有证据证明你的……当评论员说：“哦，这个来自亨斯坦顿的小伙子，他的家人正在家乡观看比赛……”我的意思是，我当时感动得泪流满面，我真是一个可怜的家伙。好吧，我接下来要讲的这个轶事将会是一个糟糕的轶事，因为我记不太清了。好吧，这是多年前别人告诉我的，好像是多伊尔·欧文，伟大的体育记者……不是社会民主党（SDP），不是SDP！不，不，是《金融时报》的体育编辑。好吧，
somebody mentioned it also on twitter a couple of days ago but it's in one of the scandinavian olympics and i'm guessing it's it's either stockholm i think it's stockholm um there's a marathon there's a japanese runner he realizes midway through that he's not going to win a medal and he's so ashamed that he stops the race and he just goes home without telling anyone so nobody knows where he's gone so he just vanishes yeah and he's gone back to tokyo and yeah and after the war the um the swedes kind of discover this happened and they invite him back to Sweden to complete the course, and he does it. And everyone turns out in Stockholm to cheer him over the finish line.
几天前也有人在推特上提到过这件事，这是在某届斯堪的纳维亚奥运会上，我猜要么是斯德哥尔摩，我想是斯德哥尔摩，那里有一场马拉松比赛，一个日本跑步运动员在半程时意识到自己拿不到奖牌了，他感到非常羞愧，于是退出了比赛，没有告诉任何人就直接回家了。所以没人知道他去哪儿了，他就这样消失了。对，他回东京了。对，战后，瑞典人发现了这件事，他们邀请他回瑞典完成这段赛程，而他也真的做到了。所有斯德哥尔摩的市民都出来为他冲过终点线呐喊助威。
That's a lovely story. So that is a good story. That's a bit like the Derek Redmond story. I mean, people who know about athletics will definitely know this story. So there was a very accomplished British runner at the beginning of the 1990s called Derek Redmond, he was played by injuries and he got himself fit I think just for Barcelona
这是一个温馨的故事。所以这确实是个好故事。这有点像德里克·雷德曼的故事。我的意思是，熟悉田径运动的人一定知道这个故事。在20世纪90年代初，有一位非常出色的英国短跑运动员叫德里克·雷德曼，他饱受伤病困扰，但我认为他刚好赶上了巴塞罗那奥运会恢复了健康。
and he was in the final and he had a really good expectation of a medal and I'm sure you have seen it Tom but his hamstring goes halfway round and he slows to a crawl a stagger,
他进入了决赛，人们对他夺牌寄予了很高的期望。我确信你一定看过那个视频，汤姆，但他的腿筋在跑了一半时拉伤了，他慢了下来，变成了一步一挪的蹒跚，
and a man runs onto the field. Yeah. A sort of older, quite sort of large black man, and the organisers are trying to sort of hold him back, but it turns out this man is his dad, and his dad helps him across the line, and it's this incredibly sort of, even the Olympic sort of hold him back but it turns out this man is his dad and his dad helps him across the line and it's this incredibly sort of even the even the olympic sort of the official olympic website makes mention of this you know because obviously he comes in behind everybody else but
这时一个男人跑进了场内。对。一个年纪稍大、身材相当魁梧的黑人男子，组织者试图拦住他，但结果证明这个男人是他的父亲，他的父亲帮他冲过终点线，这是一个非常……甚至奥运会的……奥运会官方网站都提到了这一点，你知道的，因为很显然他落后于所有人，但是
his dad is determined that he his son will finish and he basically helps him so actually you know it's it's very like the story of ferranique that we talked about in the first of our our trilogy the mother who helps her son yeah to to win the boxing of the wrestling i can't remember which it is and she's not wearing any underwear and they reckon she's not wearing any underwear and the penalty is officially that she'd be chucked off a cliff yeah that didn't happen to the redmond the ioc decided that she they'll spare her. So very similar. That's a very nice moment on which to end. And one last note on which to end, Tom,
他的父亲坚信他的儿子能够完成比赛，并亲自给予了协助。实际上，这非常像我们三部曲第一部分中谈到的那个费拉尼克的故事——那个帮助她儿子赢得拳击或摔跤比赛的母亲（我记不清到底是哪一项了），当时她没穿内衣，人们认为她真空上阵，而官方的惩罚本该是把她从悬崖上扔下去。对，雷德曼没有遭遇这种事，国际奥委会决定饶她一命。所以，这是一个非常温馨的结局时刻。最后再提一件事，汤姆，
to return to the patriotic spirit which we began these two podcasts on, the modern Olympics. Do you know there's only one country that has won a gold medal in every single Summer Games? I'll give you one guess which one. Is it the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland? It is.
回归我们讨论现代奥运会之初的爱国精神。你知道吗？只有一个国家在每一届夏季奥运会上都获得过金牌。我让你猜一个。是伟大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国吗？正是。
It is. Well, and before we became the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland, of course, we won gold in the only cricket match in Paris, 1900. So we remain the gold medal winners in cricket, and I think that's a splendid note. We win the Equalinental Olympics every year. They're the real games.
是的。在我们成为伟大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国之前，当然，我们在1900年巴黎奥运会上唯一的板球比赛中也赢得了金牌。所以我们依然是板球项目的金牌得主，我认为这是一个精彩的收尾。我们每年都赢得大洲奥运会。那才是真正的比赛。
Yeah. The Continental Olympics really it's a victory for them. Exactly. So well done them. Thanks very much for listening. We've got Sparta coming up haven't we? And lots of stuff about the Berlin Wall and nuclear weapons
对。洲际奥运会，对他们来说是一场胜利。完全正确。他们做得很好。非常感谢大家的收听。我们接下来要讲斯巴达，对吧？还有很多关于柏林墙和核武器的内容，
and tons of interesting stuff so see you soon see you next time bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及大量有趣的内容，所以我们回见，下期见，再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》，想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。